les mouches peut pas comment expliquer
l'inexplicable
les voisins de la coopérative rousselot
comme hamid fadhil y cherche encore les
mots ma fille elle était dans la même
classe ou de la fixité sa collègue il
n'est pas encore au courant de
l'incident la tragédie remonte à samedi
soir le spvm reçoit un appel
une agression à l'armé blanche survenue
dans un appartement du quartier villeray
deux fillettes deux soeurs 5 et 11 ans
sont retrouvés gravement blessé la
principale suspecte leur mère âgée de 34
ans qu'on peut identifier en vertu de la
loi est arrêté sur place et le dit
également transporté au centre
hospitalier pour y soigner des blessures
au niveau du haut du corps qu'elle
serait obligée d'elle-même elle va être
rencontré par les enquêteurs de la
section des crimes majeurs des cas
conduire vos pouvoirs le permettre le
père était sur les lieux du drame
chaviré
c'est usant l'état de choc l'oeil crié
le conflit c'était vraiment différent de
l'ensemble je pense que cris tellement
fort le monde notamment surprise c'est
silence total autour de lui il m'a dit
qu'elle a sauvé lui il a pris la petite
là il
il a protégé mais l'aînée des deux
filles âgées de 11 ans a succombé à ses
blessures à l'hôpital
l'autre repose toujours dans un état
stable
un drame qui secoue cette coopérative de
près de 80 membres une petite communauté
où logent de nombreuses familles
messieurs était très proche de ses
enfants était toujours là mais c'est
sans fin et être impliqué une personne
on m'a des trains qui ne comprennent pas
qu est ce qu a passé parce que ça
pouvait arriver
on connaît pas à la maman le malin à
n'était pas ici c'est le pen communisme
pourquoi la mère était là qu'est ce qui
l'a poussé à poser un tel geste
ta paye certains personnes aussi le
désespoir s'appelle un manque de
ressources
la personnel ça fait une escale à 2
d'événements il a quand même beaucoup
d'hypothèses
donc comme vous dites on sait pas grand
chose les circonstances doivent encore
être éclaircis mais difficile de saisir
l'incompréhensible jacques audrey les
policiers attendent toujours que l'état
de santé de la mère s'améliore avant de
l'interroger
elle était dans un état critique hier
qui se serait stabilisé mais les
enquêteurs n'ont toujours pas pu
l'interroger et d'oncle enquête n'est
pas terminé une fois que ce sera fait
dans les prochaines heures ou les
prochains jours eh bien le dossier va se
retrouver sur le bureau de la direction
des poursuites criminelles et pénales et
à ce moment là on décidera quelles
accusations seront portées
on nous indique du côté du dpcp qui aura
pas de délai supplémentaire en raison de
la situation actuelle puisque le dépôt
d'accusations encore la comparution sont
jugés comme des services essentiels en
terminant pascal il s'agit du cinquième
homicide à survenir sur le territoire
montréalais depuis le début de l'année
merci jacques audrey